(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Bom, vamos ver agora na prática como é
que funciona o pagamento e a declaração do
ganho de capital que você vai ter na
venda do imóvel.
Em primeiro lugar, você deve fazer o download
do programa de apuração de ganho de capital
da Receita Federal do ano em que você
está vendendo o imóvel.
Com uma rápida pesquisa no Google, você consegue
localizar o link e fazer o download desse
programa.
Quando você realizar o download do programa e
abrir o programa, você vai ter essa página
inicial aqui do programa.
Você vai clicar em bens e imóveis aqui
no canto esquerdo e vai abrir uma página
para você.
Esses aqui são exemplos que eu estava simulando
aqui somente para gravar essa aula.
Você vai clicar em novo e o programa
vai abrir uma nova página para você.
Essa primeira página é de identificação, então você
vai informar ali qual é o imóvel.
Vamos supor que eu arrematei o apartamento 63,
localizado na Vila Formosa.
Vou preencher aqui embaixo os dados do imóvel,
rua, endereço, o número, o número do apartamento,
o bairro, o estado, a cidade e o
CEP.
Na segunda página, na segunda aba de aquisição,
a Receita vai me perguntar a data de
aquisição.
Vamos supor que esse imóvel que eu estou
vendendo eu arrematei em 10 de agosto de
2020 em um leilão.
E agora eu vou responder a pergunta que
a Receita está fazendo.
Houve no imóvel alienado edificação, ampliação, reforma ou
trata-se de imóvel adquirido em partes em
datas diferentes?
Vamos supor que eu comprei esse imóvel aqui
à vista e eu não fiz nenhuma reforma.
Então vou colocar aqui não.
E a Receita vai me perguntar qual foi
o custo de aquisição nesse imóvel.
E aqui você já sabe o que você
pode somar nesse custo de aquisição.
Valor efetivamente pago pelo imóvel, comissão do leiloeiro,
ITBI, registro, escritura se existir e alguma reforma
que você tenha feito nesse imóvel.
Vamos supor que eu comprei esse imóvel por
200 mil reais.
Agora vamos fazer um exemplo aqui de que
eu tenha realizado alguma reforma nesse imóvel.
Então eu teria que preencher aqui sim e
o programa me apresentaria essa nova página.
E aqui nessa nova página eu tenho que
discriminar o que eu gastei com esse imóvel.
Então vamos supor que dia 10 de agosto
de 2020 eu paguei 200 mil reais nesse
imóvel.
200 mil reais nesse imóvel.
Vou colocar ok.
Vou abrir novamente e informar que dia 10
de setembro de 2020, por exemplo, eu gastei
2.500 reais com o registro desse imóvel.
Vou abrir uma nova tela e informar que
no dia 20 de setembro de 2020, por
exemplo, eu gastei 5 mil reais de reforma
com esse imóvel.
E assim por diante.
Na terceira aba a receita vai perguntar quem
são os adquirentes desse imóvel, ou seja, quem
comprou esse imóvel.
Você vai colocar que é novo, preencher CPF
e o nome da pessoa que comprou o
imóvel.
Depois na quarta aba a receita vai te
perguntar a operação.
Então eu comprei em leilão e vendi.
Vou colocar que é uma venda.
A receita vai perguntar se a leilãoação foi
a prazo ou a prestação quando a gente
vende um imóvel à vista.
A gente recebe o dinheiro de uma única
vez e quando a gente vende um imóvel
financiado a gente também recebe o dinheiro de
uma única vez.
Então vou colocar aqui que não, que não
foi.
E a data da venda?
Vamos supor que foi dia 20 de janeiro
de 2021.
A receita vai perguntar o valor da alienação,
ou seja, o valor da venda.
De forma proposital eu vou colocar aqui que
foi 440 mil reais para explicar como é
que funciona a isenção para vocês.
E por fim, nessa página eu vou preencher
o valor da corretagem.
Se fosse aqui em São Paulo esse imóvel
seria 6% sobre o valor da venda,
ou seja, R$ 26.400. Última pergunta
dessa aba, já houve alienação parcial desse bem?
Geralmente a gente vende 100% do imóvel,
então vou colocar que não, porque eu vendi
100% do imóvel.
Perguntas.
Aqui nessa aba a gente vai aplicar se
a gente quer optar por uma isenção, se
for possível optar por essa isenção ou se
não.
Então primeira pergunta que a receita faz.
Você possui outro imóvel, seja como proprietário individual,
em condomínio ou em comunhão ou como usufrutuário?
Em condomínio seria se eu tivesse esse imóvel
em conjunto com outras pessoas.
Em comunhão seria, por exemplo, se eu fosse
casada em comunhão parcial de bens.
E como usufrutuário é quando existe um usufruto
no imóvel.
Vou colocar aqui que não.
Depois disso a receita me faz uma nova
pergunta.
Nos últimos cinco anos você efetuou outra alienação
de imóvel a qualquer título tributada ou não?
Isso é para saber se eu posso usar
a isenção de R$ 440 mil do
único imóvel.
Se eu colocar aqui que eu não vendi
nos últimos cinco anos, automaticamente a receita vai
falar que eu tenho R$ 0 a
pagar de tributo sobre essa venda.
Ela vai colocar aqui que o meu rendimento
isento e não tributável é de um pouco
mais de R$ 206 mil, que corresponde
de fato ao lucro que eu tive na
venda desse imóvel.
Agora voltando aqui na aba de perguntas, se
eu falar que sim, que eu vendi outro
imóvel nos últimos cinco anos, a receita vai
me perguntar se eu quero usar a isenção
de 180 dias.
Da seguinte forma, o imóvel objeto dessa alienação
é residencial?
Se eu preencher que sim, ela vai me
perguntar novamente se o produto da alienação será
aplicado na aquisição de imóvel residencial no Brasil
no prazo de 180 dias em conformidade com
o artigo 39 da lei 11.196 de
2005.
E ela fala, caso tenha usado a isenção
dessa lei nos últimos cinco anos, ou não
deseja utilizá-la, responda não, porque de fato
você pode escolher, dentro do prazo de cinco
anos ali, quando você vai usar essa isenção.
Você não precisa usar na primeira venda desse
imóvel, você pode guardar para um momento mais
estratégico, para um imóvel que você teria que
recolher mais imposto.
Então você pode deixar essa carta na manga
para usar quando for necessário.
Vamos supor que nesse caso aqui, eu quero
usar essa isenção de 180 dias, eu vou
preencher que sim, e a receita vai me
falar o valor que eu tenho que gastar.
Esse valor aqui corresponde ao valor da venda,
vou voltar aqui nessa página, valor da venda
menos a comissão do corretor.
Então eu teria que gastar, em 180 dias,
na aquisição de um novo imóvel residencial ou
mais de um imóvel residencial no Brasil, um
pouco mais de 413 mil reais.
Preenchendo dessa forma, a receita também diz que
eu tenho zero reais a pagar.
Agora, se eu já tivesse utilizado a isenção,
ou se eu não quisesse gastar essa minha
carta na manga nesse imóvel, eu teria que
preencher que não, que eu não quero utilizar
o produto da venda para comprar outro imóvel
residencial no prazo de 180 dias.
E nesse caso, aqui na aba de consolidação,
a receita vai apresentar que eu tenho que
recolher o imposto de um pouco mais de
30 mil reais, que corresponde a 15%
do meu lucro.
Aqui nessa aba de apuração, a receita vai
mostrar como foi feito esse cálculo.
Depois que você finalizar aqui todo o procedimento,
você vem aqui no campo esquerdo, aba imprimir,
e vai clicar para imprimir a DARF.
Aqui no meu caso, eu não vou conseguir
imprimir a DARF porque eu não preenchi corretamente
ali o endereço do imóvel e os dados
do comprador.
Então a receita iria me informar que eu
teria que preencher aquilo lá corretamente para poder
então imprimir a DARF para realizar o pagamento.
Mas então é só você clicar aqui e
imprimir essa DARF.
Depois, no ano seguinte, a gente está fazendo
essa declaração da venda de um imóvel que
aconteceu em 2021.
No ano seguinte, você teria que informar na
sua declaração anual de imposto de renda as
vendas que você fez e o imposto que
você recolheu no ano anterior.
É somente clicar aqui para exportar para o
imposto de renda 2022, e todos os dados
e todas as operações que você fez aqui
nesse programa durante o ano de 2021 serão
exportados para a sua declaração de imposto de
renda em 2022.
Então é simples assim para recolher o imposto
de renda na venda do imóvel que você
arrematou em leilão.
E o programa é bem auto-explicativo, te
perguntando se você quer usar a isenção e
quando vai ser possível utilizar a isenção.